اعلنت دراسه العامه لشؤون الحرمين عن صدور
موافقه ملكيه باطلاق تسميه الرواق السعودي
على مبنى مشروع توسعه المطاف في المسجد
الحرم وبين رئيس رئاسه العامه لشؤون
الحرمين الدكتور عبد الرحمن السديس ان
الرواقه السعوديه يتضمن مشروع توسعه
المطاف خلف الرواق العباسي ويتكون من
اربعه ادوار بطاقه استيعابيه تصل الى 287
الف مصلل في الساعه وفق معايير هندسيه
عاليه
[موسيقى]
والقائمين والركع السجود لنرفع اسمى ايات
الشكر والامتنان والتقدير والعرفان للمقام
الكريم على هذه المكرومه التاريخيه
الفريده ويحق لكل مسلم ولكل سعود ان يرفع
بذلك راسا ويبدئج نفسا وينشرح صدرا ويقر
عينا بهذا الانجاز
الاستثنائي المبهر كما نرفع التهنئه مضمضه
مضيعه بالدعاء والولاء لاولاه امرنا
الميامين ثناء عاطرا ودعاء وافرا على هذه
الجهود المباركه
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا الدكتور عبد
الله الشريف استاذ كرسي الملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز لدراسات التاريخ مكه المكرمه
في جامعه ام القرى حياك الله دكتور عبد
الله معي في نشره الرابعه اولا مسياق
التاريخي
الرواق السعودي وما هي مراحل العمل على
هذا الرواق حتى
شكرا للاستضافه الكريمه والحقيقه انه
اطلاق مسمى الرواق السعودي على
العماره السعوديه وعلى الرواق السعودي
المحيط
بالرواق العباسي في المسجد الحرام امرا
يدل الحقيقة على اهتمام خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز حفظه
الله ولي عهد الامين حفظه الله بالحرمين
الشريفين حقيقه ايضا يعد انعكاسا
للرعايه الحكوميه للدوله السعوديه
المباركه
بالمسجد الحرامي منذ عهد المؤسس الملك عبد
العزيز بن عبد الرحمن ال سعود لا شك اخي
الاستاذ خالد
والمشاهدين الكرام بان من المعلوم ان
العماره عماره المسجد الحرام ظلت قرون
عديده تصل الى نحو 1200 عام على العما
العباسيه او ما عرفت بالرواق العباسي وذلك
انه من المعلوم ان الخليفه المحمد المهدي
بن ابي جعفر بن المنصور العباسي قد بنى
الرواق العباسي للمحيط بالمطاف والكعبه
المشرفه هي فتره خلافته ما بين 158 الى
169 وقد زار مكه المكرمه مرتين سنه
160 سنه
وقرر يعني عماره المسجد وتوسيعته وفعلا في
العام الاول حمل اموالا عظيمه واشرف على
امر بدايه التنفيذ ولكنه حين جاء مكه في
سنه 64 وجد ان الكعبه لا تتوسط المسجد
الحرام فامر بتوسعه المسجد الحرام من
الناحيه الجنوبيه بما هو محاذاه جبل الصفا
وحول مجرى المسيل الى ما يلاق الجبل بعد
هدم تلك
هذه العماره العباسيه التي ايضا حصل لها
زيادتين في عهد مقتدر والمعترض العباسي
اصبحت هي العماره الاسلاميه للمسجد الحرام
وضل الرواق العباسي هو الرواق الامثل
والباقي حتى قيام الدوله السعوديه اللي
نحو 1200 عام
[موسيقى]
عدا ما كان من اصلاحاتهم او ترميمات
تمت على يد الدول الاسلاميه المتعاقبه بعد
الدوله العباسيه وصولا الى الدوله
السعوديه المباركة ما هو الرواق العباسي
بس لو في تفاصيل عنه دكتور عبد الله
الرواق العباسي هو البناء المحيط بالمطاهي
وبالكعبه المشرفه والرواق هو ما كان بين
صفين من الاعمده ما بين صفين من الاعمده
وقد بني في العهد العفاسي على اعمده عده
بنحو 496 عمودا
سخرت لها السفن من البحر الاحمر ومن
الخليج العربي وصولا الى ميناء الشعيبه ثم
الى المسجد الحرام وسقف بخشب الساجي
طبقتين
استخدمت من بلاد الهند وزينت وزخرفه
ولولنت وكان هذا من باب يعني حجب اشعه
الشمس عن المصلين وايضا لتدوم فتره طويله
وقيل انه استخدم فيها عماره متينه ومبتكره
حتى استطاعت الصمود هذا الوقت الطويل الذي
قدر بنحو 1200
عام
فالرواق كلما كان بين صفين من الاعمده
ويكون مسامت ومحاذي لجدار القبله في
المسجد الحرم
البناء السعودي او ما يسمى الان الرواقه
السعودي الذي اطلق هذا المصطلح اليوم هو
الحقيقه يعني عماره سعوديه عظيمه مرت بث
الراحل اساسيه
فالمؤسس العظيم الملك عبد العزيز بن عبد
الرحمن ال سعود رحمه الله منذ ان دخل مكه
واستظلت بظل دولته المباركه عمل على
الاهتمام بالمسجد الحرام ورممه وصانه
وحسنه وكذلك المسعى وظلله وكثير من
الاعمال التي قام بها الا انه توج تلك
الاعمال بالرغبه في بناء رواق سعودي يحيط
بالرواق العباسي ويوسع على المسلمين
ويستوعب هذه الاعداد الكبيره وتم هذا
البناء في عهد الملك سعود بن عبد العزيز
رحمه الله واطلق سنه
1375 واستمر في عهد الفيصل وفي عهد الملك
خالد رحمهم الله جميعا وكان هذا ما يسمى
بالتوسعه السعوديه الاولى الا ان هذه
التوسعه الحقيقه لم تكن توسعه فقط بل كانت
عباره اسلاميه عظيمه
اليوم دكتور عبد الله واعذرني على
مقاطاعتك ما الذي يتميز به الرواق السعودي
في توسعه الجديده
والى اي مدى هناك يعني محافظه او اهتمام
بالمحافظه على الهويه التاريخيه في كل
المراحل اللي مرت وخصوصا اليوم ربما
اولا يعني اخذ في الاعتبار في
العماره السعوديه ان التصاميم هذه العماره
تكون تصاميم اسلاميه
متميزه وراقيه فذات روح اسلامي كما حافظت
على بعض العناصر العناصر الاساسيه في
المسجد الحرام وان تبقى قائمه ومشهوده كما
حافظت على بعض النقوش وعلى الاعمده بعض
الاعمده القديمه القادره على الاستمرار
ولكن هذه العماره عملت على مستوى في
العماره السعوديه الاولى على ثلاثه ادوار
القبو والدور الارضي والدور الاول وكذلك
المسع وهذا يعني نقله معماريه كبيره جدا
في المسجد الحرام توسعه السعوديه الثانيه
الملك فهد الله يرحمه اضاف الى المسجد
الحرام التسعوديه التاليه وهي مكان السوق
الصغير او ما يسمى بسوق الحجره قديما وهي
ايضا توسعه
فيها احدث الاساليب المعماريه ثم في عهد
الملك عبد الله بن عبد العزيز رحمه الله
امر بالتوسعه السعودي الثالثه في الناحيه
الشماليه للمسجد الحرام
وحينما تولى خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز تفضل
وجهها وجهها باستثمالها ودشن المرحله
الاولى منها وبفضل الله ومنته هي الان
تستكمل وهي في مراحلها الاخيره
وقد اضافت الى المسجد الحرام بعدا عظيما
من حيث الحقيقه ان التوسعه السعوديت ايضا
امتازت بجمال التصميم ممتازت باستخدام
افضل
المواد وهذا تم في جميع التوسعات السعوديه
ثلاث التصاميم المميزه وايضا استخدام افضل
المواد المتاحه معماريا وايضا الزخارف
والثريات الراقيه واستخدام الرخام في الا
والرخام المقاومه لحراره الشمس واصبح
المسجد الحرام يستوعب الان نحو مليونين
مصمم في ان واحد واصبح المطاف يستوعب نحو
107 107 الف طائف في الساعه وبهذا اصبح
الرواق السعودي يمثل عماره اسلاميه تعد
ايقونها عالميه لقد اصبح المسجد الحرام من
اعظم المباني واكبرها مساحه واكثرها
استيعابا على مستوى العالم وليس على مستوى
الوطني في المملكه العربيه السعوديه شكرا
لك الدكتور عبد الله بن حسين الشريف استاذ
كرسي الملك سلمان لدراسات تاريخ مكه
المكرمه في جامعه ام القرى شكرا لك دكتور
يعطيك العافيه
[موسيقى]